how's it going bros my name is ah my
boss is out fire
why is my eyes closed seriously I miss
face Rick it's like the best thing ever
Halloween worship baby
[Music]
nipples are [ __ ] nipples and clades I'm
gonna catch more nipples and klitz
nipples templates nipple Sinclair's I'm
gonna get more but she can never see
kids nipples and clicks I'm gonna get
some more hard as i strangle you [ __ ]
you from an ankle to penetrate you ran a
prostate gland saliva dangle haha
there's a war going on outside no way to
say from you can run but you can't hide
forever from these streets that we don't
jerk you're walking with your head down
scared and look you shook cuz they know
such things as halfway crooks is that
ass play some of that ass
they were right it's a grueling stop you
better clean the heats up I like clean
and [ __ ] paints between your body will
get you sleep but I saw some ass your
day get it's funny cuz I'm a cat Tom I
talk a lot about cuddle my cuddle my
cuddle my cuddle my be even more the
[ __ ] made by this in the short time to
get another precious saw the rusty step
eyes are the crowd steers the song
siliceous the friends at rusty his word
no that could have been the one way to
put the right time the hitch under you
made or under your posit I'm gonna get
your Monday deposit put it up in the
sink I think I already have lost it I
could have been on the road saw the
dusty it's the wings are the gonna play
play play play play
they hate it hey hey hey hey hey I just
want to you're not even lip-synching it
you would not believe your ass
[Music]
fines I'm Best Buy - nice maintenance -
bye I can't I'm sorry this video has
been the dumbest video ever I am so
sorry that you had to enjoy it but I had
a lot of fun and that's all that matters
right I hope you boys had fun as well as
always thanks for hitting that like
button and I'll see you in the next
episode stay awesome bros
[Music]